so you wait you play a nerd on the show
but not in magazines look at this this
this is the hottest picture ever what is
this for oh yeah
thank you yeah so I need you to play
this character I would love to play that
character
um what happened was we were like you
know what I want people to see me in a
bit of a Different Light well done thank
you yes I like to exercise school with
art as well to see people like not in
like tight cast the same thing I
remember I was watching this as us I
think it was the first season and your
character Randall had like a shirtless
scene yeah and all of a sudden I was
like oh my God this man's ripped too
like yeah let's go like for the Nerds
nose workouts
I'm a ripped nerd as wow totally here's
my shirtless moment I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]